I believe that whenever there are big
events such as World Championship or
candidates or Olympia or World Cup or
well there are few of those every one or
two years it just makes sense for
everyone doesn't matter the level pretty
much to uh focus on them so instead of
just opening some book and looking at
some I don't know good night versus a
bad bishop or some sacrifice on F7 or
whatever they would put in any of those
books maybe we can get to see some ideas
from some of the games and just get to
see little bit of the World Cup games so
we have some very good games actually I
think kamsky played uh he played the
worst game of the tournament which
obviously we will start with or at least
the most entertaining one and then he
played definitely the best game of the
tournament which is his game against mov
yesterday so he's he was exactly on both
sides so we'll start with this game and
let's see what we can study from from
this game actually the critical position
is going to start around move 20 but
let's get
there so actually kamsky won the first
game the first game with the white
pieces so all he needed was a draw here
to
qualify okay they plays the king
Gambit okay this is one of many many
lines it's not really that critical for
us to analyze it well the the big point
is just that black played D5 is
basically like giving up back the pawn
just in order to get fast development
doesn't want to keep the pawn and stay
behind okay C6 has been played Bishop
back I assume that without much
analyzing if take on C3 pretty much
something like this would follow whether
exchanging queens or not after take on
F4 well let's let's for example play it
this way and why white is supposed to be
more pleasant here just as pair of
Bishops Bishop E6 will result in a
weakness on
E6 white is just more pleasant
here okay we will Cruise slowly to our
position A4 Knight
D7 take take okay I think already here
I'm not certain if black should be that
happy giving
white that Center I think black played
like didn't play that well just just
looking at that I mean let's look two
more moves what happened
okay so black is already I think well
unless he has something against white
king he has a problem he has no no
Center and F4 is
weak and okay very soon this is the
position they
got what do you think about this
position stin it's stks what to
do
why well the uh
Black's pieces are all
disorganized White's got the pawn center
with the Knight on F3 black Knight's
over here
H5
unprotected yeah I I I like the a lot
the pawn chain against the dark color
Bishop which is and white is equal
material black black is in big trouble
here I mean I I think his trouble
started when white played A4 and he
played C6 and he basically exchange the
a pawn with the c Pawn I'm not certain
why why I would give that c Pawn but
okay Knight E5 that looks good attacking
H5 attacking
F4 okay defending H5 defending F4
everyone's happy Queen
D3
okay
does black have any has any threat in
this position in this one let's first of
all think if he has any threat in this
position what what would would this
threat
be right
here I don't think that black has any
threat
here specifically
here I do not see any
threat because okay well let's then see
does that have any threat
here well which apparently the US
champion for 2013 couldn't see a tactics
that yeah several 1500 that's in the
game like in that
right
right so what we
play Queen takes
H2
yeah yeah I mean that that's I mean this
this game has like at least I think
three point three moments that the
evaluation change by somewhere between 6
seven to 10 points I mean
that's I mean bullet game seems more
solid than this one
but but but let's go back and move in
this position there might not be any
threat right because let's say white
just plays okay Rook B1 beautiful
move because now I
think okay it it's maybe winning maybe
winning a pawn
right but actually losing a piece so
absolutely no threat for for
black actually not not very clear what
no I mean Rook F2 is like one of those
self self-made puzzles right because
they had to take the square because if
not let's say we play Just Bishop
D2 man that's interesting game
okay yeah and then Knight F3 can always
be played I mean this this is a very
important defensive
idea yeah if I remember okay I remember
computer line our computer is actually
super happy about this
move he he doesn't he likes this move
super duper because his idea is here he
wants to play
this
this this and then he's so happy that he
can take back like I think it was like
plus five plus six for black something
something not really that
bad okay so this is number
one
okay Knight
G3 well what should white play
here well black is threatening checkman
that's not really that
bad
yes I like
defending defending okay we all do so
Knight F3 is
good
okay and take is not bad
yeah if if take this
way then just R go somewhere
right H2 is defended and H6 is under
attack but here it's amazing
position okay what to play here have you
seen it like
analysis yeah no because this amazing
this is this is another Plus
I think plus seven seven six seven
points right from plus 5 plus 6 to minus
one no
this no but
okay all right so this is a check me so
we have basically two moves to
play we can move the king or we can move
the Rook I mean okay are we going to put
it to a vote or we'll think and choose
one okay let's start with moving the
king black is going to take
right and what's Happening
Here If The Rook
move what is black going to
play which one Queen H1 Queen H1 okay
white will block with the
Knight
Rook F6 so basically doesn't matter
where they R goes on the second rank
this this is going to be impossible for
white to play
okay so
then white is getting into a big
adventure something like that okay let's
let's stop here for a second
and see the other alternative before
we're going to start looking at all this
big adventure maybe the other position
is great for it looks very suspicious
but what happen if we play differently
what happen if we move the
Rook this this is by the way I think a
very important way to be able to analyze
lines white white had I think the times
are pretty correct so white had like a
ton of time time like 20 minutes and
really strong players right I mean not
everyone has to be 2800 to be called a
really strong player I mean those are
really really strong
players so 20 minutes and okay what
after Rook F1 we had we had an idea King
F1 looks messy at best for white maybe
maybe worse but what here where is the
problem here for
white
H but if you take on G3 okay either I
get checkmated or
not I have to take the
Rook so no Checkmate
there and nothing much here also pretty
much
resign yeah actually now I remember
computer was at plus seven after Rook F1
plus
7even and after King F1 maybe minus one
one and the half so like basically like
he blunder the queen like it's equal to
like playing something like that just to
no King
F1
take yeah actually this is probably way
better than
take because no not not easy to defend
this one no and here and here the
problem for
for for white that okay he's worse
anyway but he lost the first game
so
well black doesn't need to find anything
more than that and actually all other
alternatives are horrible for white I
mean King King E3 was best I mean was
just somewhat worse don't remember
exactly how much but all other
alternatives are
horrible no okay but play
this
this maybe this was also possible
but something like
that also looks
pretty pretty okay for black for
yeah oh wait play
this yeah and here here a bit
tricky I mean a bit tricky but again
what to play
here yeah ksky lo I think if this is the
moment lost the game immediately
here but what would be a logical move to
play here one or two or few whichever
one that you
want just to play something what would
be
but Rook F3 okay if I'll just take with
the
queen just Queen take queen queen take
G1 King go
somewhere
that's which
one just take no one one thing one thing
important here we're going to see this
we're going to see several other games
and the thing that I think we can study
from those is one well everyone blunders
and it's really fun when they have 20 27
or 28 next to their numbers especially
on the left side it's very fun no but I
mean believing the opponent too much
it's
okay like I mean not every sacrifice is
worth something and like
I know many people yeah it's not easy
not to do that they just say wow my
opponent is so strong and you cannot
have
blundered but the truth is that yeah
most people many people I mean actually
blunder a lot and being saved by their
opponents believing them many many I
mean we will see actually some more this
you know if there is something to study
from the at least the two or three next
game that I want to show from this
tournament is that yeah believing
opponent too much
is not correct okay but what to play
with
black we have Bishop takes D4 that I
just take it say thank you be happy Rook
take F3 I do exactly the same
so Bishop G4 yeah this is the move
someone else
suggested when I show the game Bishop G4
is not bad Bishop
G4 I think Queen take here and something
like this is kind of is is very
dangerous because if blocking then Rook
F3 is going to come yeah this this is
quite bad this is one idea I think
Bishop E6 is the best move or one of the
best moves I mean just want to open the
position and okay I mean this just
looks nothing to discuss
I think Bishop B6 Bishop H3 is super
strong like all of those are like plus
five plus six plus whatever like G2
excellent no the thing the thing is
that it's very interesting to try and
understand what kamsky
missed I think I I think I have an idea
what he missed but okay he wants to play
Rook F1 and like just resign right the
opponent like immediately resigned so
basically it's like a winning a game
threat so how to stop Rook
F1 I think there's one way
right you know maybe I will do it this
way I will let you think here I want I
want you to maybe tell me what you think
kamski Miss because I think White's
moves is obvious but I
think think I know what he missed but I
want to hear from
you which one no but Rook F2 is obvious
move yeah Rook F2 you're right this is
the move that was played it's a very
good move I think that what he
missed somehow I feel that he saw F
two that's my feeling I think that he
missed that after Queen
86 that his Queen is under attack that's
my feeling because probably okay he
doesn't have so much he say Okay Rook F2
Queen H6 take on F2 or King E2 Queen H5
and finish I think that that's what he
missed no it's interesting to understand
why when a player plays something and
they are really really strong players
what he missed I'm pretty certain this
is what he
overlooked no because no way that he
overlooked Rook F2 I mean possible but
yeah but after Rook F2 is it's amazing
Bishop from winning to just losing I
mean this is the third or fourth
somewhere between seven to 10 points
change in one one move yeah yeah here is
it wasn't that losing immediately but
okay just went and lost the
game pretty much on the spot he his
opponent gave him no no more chances
anymore kind of funny
position but he just played white played
very very good this is a very good move
like allowing the queen Freedom The Rook
is here
defending yeah just went on and one and
actually also okay here there are many
moves that are winning I just I I kind
of like me personally maybe there is
something even better but I really like
White's play just get the king back you
know doesn't need to take the B5 Pawn
all he needs is just to kind of put the
King on D2 and the pawns are not
mobilized anymore so okay so this was
one one funny game but but I think most
likely the so far the funniest game of
the tournament but there were several
others really important games that had
big tactical moments especially one one
that was I thought quite amazing between
this young Chinese kid know that's going
to be very very strong Apparently kid
against mov and he was probably well he
had a very good position with black and
let's see what happened
there
okay
okay opening is not really that
important yeah somehow black seems to
have zero problems here
right actually I I I'll be honest I
didn't even see the entire the entire
opening I just seen it when M was a pie
down for quite some pawns but okay D5 is
logical take take
Bishop
C4 okay this is actually I I guess it
started here
right I guess it started
here maybe a bit
dangerous for looks dangerous for black
for example after
Castle what shall we play here I'm
thinking about this move maybe maybe
just totally crazy
but this move
no but it's kind of scary Bishop takes
here now want to play this
move I mean most likely I mean it's
either really really smart or super
stupid most likely it's super stupid but
I mean just not really easy to defend
this
one no this actually interesting I
didn't see
that Queen D6 Queen D7 I will take on I
will take on
B6 Knight A5 I will take on
C7 and if not I just threaten to take
on on um C6 Bishop B3 Bishop B5 maybe I
can play this
move maybe Knight
A5 maybe this move here and then
C6 maybe it's too
much H you did you have a dou
check yeah but the double check where is
it
leading oh for the
worken
yeah I mean for example I can play this
move okay if I had the Rook on the third
rank I'll be so happy I'll play this
give check give check on H3 to put it in
a
puzzle can play I Can can win the queen
but for about bazillion pieces it's it's
not going to make it right so this this
is not happy no but somehow it looks D
so
dangerous take is this
move yeah I cannot I cannot get back to
the diagonal to play I mean okay let me
play Queen A2 I'll be happy because then
I'm on the diagonal
but
so no okay of course possible just to
play just something simple like just
move Knight to C3 but you know this this
to me is super
forcing most forcing lines because for
example I don't know if Queen D6 okay of
course we we just threaten to take on B6
it's it's just very very forcing this
line I mean if it's working white
White's going to be very very very very
happy
here if it's
working so let's see again Rook D2
Bishop
B5 nothing
much ah wait a second can I take
you take
you no this is this is not bad cuz I
will have
this
yeah but this I I'm not a believer in
line I'll take I mean it starts to look
artificial okay in a second we will
crack down and see what computers say no
this I don't believe I mean A2 A2 the
pieces are just too good
here Queen C4
B5
yeah so even this is not so
clear okay let's
see let's see what Mr computer I don't
even know how to make it work here my
goodness all right we are without him so
let's say that this was interesting and
we we'll go home and see what What's
Happening Here No but okay you played I
mean mov obviously played very similar
idea yeah why can't
I oh because it's
Dasher how do
I okay play this move
take
take yeah actually interesting
what interesting what he played because
Knight C3 there is Queen takes F4
check and if C4 just Queen C5 for
example no actually Queen C5 not going
to work so what after C4
no because C4 is more slow one move now
I mean Queen Bishop pin
attack actually this this was the
blunder in the game by the way Rook Pawn
this just missed the simple pin so maybe
maybe they had problem with pins here
but I don't know they could not have
missed C4 I'm just trying to see what we
missed
yeah okay it's not really missed I I was
thinking about ideas to go to end game
but
okay yeah I just didn't think it will be
so strong I mean okay he has to play
Queen E7 I was actually thinking about
idea we'll see it in a second about
Queen F6 but the queen is not getting
trapped so getting the the Queen the
pawn is Tiny better than
C4 here Queen E7 and take on on
G2 okay that was his only line nothing
nothing clear
but okay so this was one moment here
you
yeah okay they play this no but actually
there was a pin that they missed in the
game here
here oh right this
position
yeah okay what to play here with black I
mean this this was really I mean this
kid beat Nei beat Sidler like made two
draw sh sh starts with an S seems the
same right no and made two easy draws in
the rapid against M no I just played
like
201800 but here
amazing
when I remember I looked at it and I
thought black is I don't know simplest
simplest move in the position sometimes
not sometimes most of the times the
simplest moves are the best just the
best you know what what what would
probably most people playing a Blitz
game here is to E6 Rook to E6 right I
mean it's attacking the Knight defending
the pawn like Rook to E6
it's just most obvious move no this was
amazing okay had 3 minutes but
apparently not too
strong so so what's wrong with okay at
least I understand he play this move
thinking that he's going to trap the
Knight right that was too smart
idea and what's the problem with this
move
huh right that that's just what he
missed it's
amazing amazing I mean after after I
think
here this has to be
played something like
this but this just really bad mean maybe
C what
what yeah C5 is not bad right
actually in this line C5 is not
bad because here here there's a
Checkmate here and you just put the
bishop on F3 and that looks kind of good
for
black more more kind of like
winning I remember there was I remember
there was a line that was a bit less
clear but but still black was about
winning here but actually this
is yeah this is just not bad for black
like Rook E6
like yeah so he played
C6 Rook takes E4 and okay
actually not easy to play this position
it's supposed to be about equal but no
no not easy to
play yeah and this this is another this
what saves what saves white again yeah
he was really playing to trap the Knight
and but
here already very very bad it's four
pawns and at some point they will Mo be
mobilized I mean actually it's
interesting computer said it's not not
that easy but I just think that for
computer maybe maybe he can say it's
okay for
humans I thought it's just
lost okay and why it went okay very very
slow simple whatever at some point he
will push the pawn
yeah I guess he he just thought it okay
after take
take this cannot be stopped I mean sorry
G4 and H5 and F5 I mean it's it's four
pawns yeah what why didn't play here
this
move
just this move with G4
is maybe bishop D5 okay played slower
not
important yeah I'm in this position even
if computer say at some point was okay
is okay I mean he just lost without any
game I mean just impossible to play
so resigned here but amazing you know
some one it's it's just super important
game okay mov is already out of the
tournament so really not that critical
maybe the kid could have been somewhere
else but again in this position the move
that I I really think that in a Blitz
game May May let's assume that C6 is
winning the knight in a very complicated
way how many of us would really play
that and think about it in an
instinct I think Rook E6 probably most
players will just automatically play and
it's the best one the last position I
think well maybe we'll have another one
but is was also
very very very important and actually
they are still playing it's a game
between Le Wang and Sidler that actually
had one very very interesting moment
there but no and actually had a very
decent position here very decent so they
play this
Scotch okay it's one of the main
lines whatever whatever nothing special
has been done
here actually kind of easy position I
mean black just played normal moves
and yeah I think I think there was some
very complicated line I think actually
this crazy move if I remember okay
something like
this anyway better to
take yeah Compu computer kind of like
King B8 in previous moves and so on
maybe instead of
G6 or King B8 now at some point no but
here he played here and F5 okay what's
the idea of F5 I think A5 is a very good
idea just it's losing the
game so what what's the idea of
F5 yeah I I think it achieved many it's
fighting for the f file not allowing
Rook F6 fighting against this bishop
exactly I
mean probably let's say if White's
Bishop was on a normal Square let's say
C3 and the Knight somewhere I think G4
would be okay for example if we play
those two beautiful
moves okay somehow this would make a lot
of
sense and actually actually it would be
very
funny in this
line this line can be really funny
because take is I think very much in
still in White's
favor the pawn is very dangerous I think
so which is not not far away from
actually what happened in the game in no
so I think F5 is basically to block the
The Rook the file the
whatever but okay for people that didn't
see the game what should white play he
played one move
actually just that yeah okay and Gand I
guess wasn't in the mood to play Queen
F7 and see how the game continues yeah
what what what did he miss like I mean
probably just take take take and just
that the
ponies yeah that's that's not so much
fun no but he played so strong like
everything like
all right now let's see two two last
games okay this one they are still
battling tomorrow and this this dude is
really strong like he won the blit World
Championship he probably more impressive
he beat Guk than winning the because the
world B Championship really was not that
strong actually oh Guk played yeah but
but many it wasn't as strong as many
previous
years yeah that's that's your job to
tell
me okay so they played very good boring
but tiny better line for white no no
it's good it's good to play this way
like when you grew up on Anderson and
all those things you are like happy in
this
position anyway no the white white is
white is
better all the way actually this is very
interesting how what to do with the King
cuz it's not easy where where to put the
king how to put the king but I've seen
some games like this they many different
version they play this and F5 and they
put the king
here yeah not in the
center
okay okay so they got into this position
white white is better
all tiny better all the way but here
this is the point I wanted to show
okay so this is the position and
actually to be honest when I first
looked at that I didn't fully understand
the idea I I understood something but I
missed the tactics that just Mak
something much much stronger here
so you know what to play you know
everything what's that you know there
two you you you know living on those
chest side should replace
me no but actually this this this was
interesting I I had my reason to play
the other move but the E takes eex is
the simplest
move but okay let's first of all see
what happens with e most logical move
okay Knight takes C5 what
now again very super simple move what is
the most logical move that we will play
automatically H there are two moves
actually
D6 is one move agree
another which
one yeah maybe this will maybe move the
king
something you cannot I don't think you
can take right cuz I will take take and
this no okay yeah has to play King G6
maybe maybe still something like
that the Knight and push
the yeah actually this this maybe Rook
E1 bothers me more but this and if I go
here yeah actually actually this timey
trouble for
white yeah Rook rookie one
win this this this rookie one right yeah
this I don't
like but I'll take on
D7 I'll just take on D7 know I mean like
for example this position but you're
threatening nothing let's say just go
here well I take
no I can actually also take this way
because it's
defended yeah not easy to defend D7
here yeah take take here may be also
possible but no no power to look at some
of those
things no but just okay Bishop F6 just
enough to stop the line but I think this
is more serious
no yeah this I actually don't like I
mean D6 looks looks also not bad for
white this6 and this move is look
looking very
logical just just immediate threats here
and actually black black rep is quite
forc here
seriously
h
yeah I mean I
I I I don't like to look so much at
those things cuz it looks like just much
better version of previous ones and so
on no black has to sacrifice The
Exchange and blockade and prey something
like that no but it's not so I
mean it's not so horrible and
practically for human I mean okay this
is a weakness and those are really not
that good
and yeah actually he made the draw super
easy I think white could have played
better but he made super easy draw it
just looks horrible
like I mean very soon it's going to be
better
here yeah but but but of course white
was better I was thinking at the
beginning I'll tell you what I was
thinking that I want to get this
version I want to get this version like
okay I want to
play the same
thing but just without
rugs and this looks this looks kind of
nice
for for black for white because if I'm
up material especially when you up like
exchange you want to get Rooks off the
board as quickly as possible just the
Dynamics of the piece
but I I I I wasn't looking at the lines
and I just see the computer was at plus
three and by the way many times it's
enough you don't need to see the
computer move but you just understand
okay this was not plus three so I missed
something before and then I said
oh that was the thing just because
computer
so what did I
miss that's what someone that didn't see
the analysis going to tell me what did I
miss after Rook takes D5 Rook takes
D5 and so on the continuation that we
mentioned take take on E5 and so
on I mean two strong
players miss that also so not that bad
but you are not going to miss
it
E4
D5 yeah but this this what was played in
the
game which line you
mean Pawn take D5 or Rook takes
D5 this way but the Knight will take
this what happened in the game and okay
white is better
but
Tak e takes
F I'm kind of like a rook up no okay
I'll take without
thinking E6
when beginning
when this
move yes I'll
take
so going to be a long night until we get
something y p down what's that like you
know people
like like we winchest my material
like my to
personation but okay they they're just
combining some ideas here would allow us
to finish this one and maybe see
something
else Bop was said no it wasn't if it was
played yeah e Tak was played and Rook
Tak his is winning the game winning but
why ah finally thank you no amazing but
but it's so easy to miss it I mean I
said I like this because I thought I can
get the same line just okay I I'm so
much happier I mean okay I think
objectively this is much much better
than the game so yeah like 10% correct
but no more than that but but this
designing I mean new game just like
really really new
game no that's
amazing
yeah I mean probably Best Best Line I
think was something like
this something like this take
take but it's not going to be very happy
here
yeah so
amazing